toujours en france les pouces d'un
médecin urgentiste mort du co vie 19 et
dépose plainte contre x pour homicide
involontaire et non-assistance à
personne en danger et omission de porter
secours
eric loupiac est décédé le 23 avril
dernier après avoir testé positif le 17
mars selon à sa femme il a contracté le
virus à l'hôpital de lons le saunier là
où il exerçait elle reproche au
directeur de l'hôpital de n'avoir pas
équiper les médecins de masques ffp2 à
l'epr aussi le système de tri des
patients au sein de l'hôpital il en
place seulement le 16 mars
avant cette date seuls médecins et
patients potentiellement atteints ducobu
19,6 pouvait entrer en contact sans plus
de restrictions et pour en parler en
direct avec nous antoine veil l'avocat
de claire nous pjak
bonjour merci d'être en direct et avec
nous sur rt france racontez-nous est ce
que vous savez comment éric loupiac
l'époux de votre client a contracté le
coc u19 on sait avec certitude que il a
contracté ce virus sur son lieu de
travail parce que des quinze jours avant
les mesures de confinement officiel le
docteur loupiac et son épouse s'étaient
auto confiné et donc la seule zone dans
laquelle il était en fait en contact
avec des corps étrangers était son lieu
de travail
donc il a probablement contracté ce
virus à l'hôpital en soignant des gens
et surtout dans un contexte qui l'avait
pointé du doigt et qui mettaient en
danger la sécurité du personnel soignant
par le défaut notamment de masques
adéquat et par différentes manquements
notamment le fait que les malades
n'étaient pas trier correctement et qui
ont probablement été la cause de son
décès on va revenir de c est ce qu il a
été testé avant de présenter des
symptômes le docteur roux pjak
non je connais pas tous les détails du
cheminement et c'est ce que l' enquête
va devoir établir c'est à dire tous les
manquements et toutes les étapes qui ont
conduit effectivement à sa contamination
puis à son décès ce que je sais c'est
que c'est quelqu'un qui avait pris la
pleine mesure en fait de la gravité de
la situation qui avait comme je vous
l'expliquais décidé de s'auto confiné de
se faire livrer les courses et qui
s'appliquait à lui et à sa famille des
mesures très strictes
mais c'est vrai que contrairement à ce
qu'il avait pointé dès le début
l'hôpital son employeur l'endroit dans
lequel il travaillait n'avait pas selon
nous mis en place des mesures
suffisantes pour garantir cette sécurité
alors est ce que l'hôpital a fourni un
masque ffp2 à eric à loupiac dès le
début de l'épidémie
non c'est l'enjeu même de me plaindre
c'est l'enjeu de l'enquète que nous
demandons est que nous souhaitons voir
ouvrir c'est à dire que il est manifeste
que en raison peut-être d'ailleurs de la
vitesse de la crise en raison du fait
que peut-être l'administration a été
dépassée c'est à dire les raisons les
justificatifs seront avancées dans un
second temps nous ce qui nous importe
c'est de pouvoir établir les manquements
qui ont pu causer sa mort et qui ont
fait que ce médecin urgentiste très
connue très respecté très engagé au sein
de la profession a malheureusement été
contaminés d'une part alors que médecin
il était évidemment très informés de la
façon dont il fallait recevoir les
patients lui-même et d'autre part qu'il
en est et c'est ça le sort tragique de
ce dossier décédé alors les pots de
votre cliente a présenté un des
recommandations à l'hôpital notamment ça
n'a pas été suivi savez vous de quel
genre de recommandations sont j il
s'agissait notamment de recommandations
permettant un meilleur tri des patients
c'est à dire que selon le récit de
madame loupiac
il y avait dès le début une vraie
difficulté puisque on recevait dans le
même hall l hôpital des gens qui
venaient se faire soigner pour des
maladies diverses et des gens qui
venaient en présentant les symptômes du
coït donc déjà il y avait apparemment
pas de mise en place d'un système
garantissant on va dire une étanchéité
des cas qu'ovide par rapport aux autres
et ensuite les mais les personnels
médicaux se retrouver face à des gens
qui étaient probablement très contagieux
ils sont le matériel à leur disposition
une
ensemble les masques qui permettait
l'étanchéité et l'absence de
contamination
donc on va pas faire l'enquète avant l'
enquête est l'enjeu de notre dépôt de
plainte c'est pas de dire qu'on sait
tout ce qui a été mal fait on sait qu'il
y en a suffisamment pour justifier une
démarche judiciaire de la part de la
veuve de monsieur luca alors comme le
dit votre cliente un enjeu c'est de
savoir enfin de trouver les coupables de
ces négligences pourquoi avoir déposé la
plainte contre x
d'abord plein de contre x est très
commun c'est-à-dire que quand on
identifie pas un auteur des faits mais
constitue dans une complexité de fait
ont saisi le procureur de la république
de certains faits et c'est ensuite au
procureur de la république de tirer la
lumière sur les faits et de voir quelles
qualifications et quels responsables
plus largement beaucoup de personnes se
demandent pourquoi on n'a pas ciblé des
échelons plus médiatiques symbolique ou
politique et on répond à ça que la
démarche de madame loupiac c'est pas
faire de la politique ou de l'idéologie
c'est véritablement d'obtenir une
enquête et une décision de justice
donc c'est une démarche judiciaire qui
est maintenant entre les mains du
parquet compétent pour tirer la lumière
sur ces faits donc selon vous les
responsabilités sont partagées l'hôpital
et l'état non mais on ne peut pas faire
les conclusions d'une enquête de justice
avant l'enquète de justice si je vous
disais déjà quels étaient les
responsabilités ça veut dire que
j'aurais pu faire une citation directe
et est directement envoyé les
responsables devant le tribunal
correctionnel
ce n'est pas la démarche que nous avons
fait nous déposerons une plainte
on a pointé à l'autorité judiciaire des
faits précis qui nous paraissent
suffisamment grave pour justifier notre
démarche
l'enquète va avoir lieu et il faut pas
que d'ores et déjà on tire les
conclusions d'une enquête qui n'a pas
encore commencé
merci à beaucoup antoine et d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes l'avocat de claire loupiac
merci d'avoir est en direct